you know that insufferable cop officer
dunn
the one who said he was called all sorts
of terrible names on the basis of race
he had no evidence of this whatsoever
cameras all over the place that day
zillions of hours of video but no we
never found
any evidence of the dubious events he's
describing so officer dunn has something
to say about enemies of the state
he says that the people at the capitol
the people who
stole pelosi's lectern were much much
worse
than the blm rioters who burned the
country down first amendment protest is
what this country is about
the first amendment the constitution
like that's the democracy of it but once
you start
attacking people attacking things then
that's wrong
and that and you know what that goes to
the riots this summer
they were wrong if you peacefully
protest then sure but the riots and the
the violence and the damage this summer
they were wrong they were wrong and
that's the exact same thing that
happened at the capitol
but their goal was to overthrow
democracy
which is a bigger threat to america
wow big of you to say that that killing
dozens of people and burning down
businesses and homes and courthouses too
big of you to say that that's wrong
hey look i'm a reasonable guy okay i
think killing dozens of people is wrong
thanks thanks man okay i'm glad we can
at least agree on that
but that's the exact same thing that
happened at the capitol no it's not
no it's not they're not even close
burning down city after city after city
killing person after person after person
burning down police station after police
station after federal courthouse
stealing property after property after
property and threatening to do it again
with the explicit support of
of members of the the democrat congress
and senate and the sitting vice
president now
that is not the same as making a mess of
nancy pelosi's desk it's not it's not
even close
they are completely incomparable events
and yet we're now being not only is he
saying they're the same
he's actually he's actually then later
saying what happened at the capitol is
worse because they want to overthrow
democracy
burning down the courthouse that's
federal court does that's not
overthrowing democracy
burning down the symbol of the justice
system that's that's not overthrowing
democracy
but jumping up and down with a horn hat
on that is
pathetic pathetic so what are we going
to do about it
we're just going to complain right
that's what we're going to do i think
the only people who are who are doing
their job
in in this entire fiasco and i hate to
toot my own horn
but it's those of us on the communicator
side of it it's those of us
in the conservative media it's those and
i'm not saying
look i think it'd be much better if
legislators were actually taking action
or judges were taking action or people
with real hard political power were
taking action
but all we can do if you have a
microphone all you can do is call
attention to this stuff
that the mainstream media won't talk
about all you can do is call attention
to not only what's happening in the news
but what that what that relates to from
a philosophical perspective from a
historical perspective you can provide
context
you can lay out the plan of what to do
but
if you're not sitting in congress if
you're not sitting
in the senate if you're not a legislator
if you're not in the bureaucracy if
you're not a judge
then you don't have that hard political
power to do something
so do something do something guys
yo i need you to subscribe to my show
not just here on youtube i appreciate
that but i need you right now before you
move on i know there's going to be more
videos
go to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play type in the michael knowles
show click that subscribe button maybe
leave a five-star review if you wouldn't
mind
really really appreciate it helps us
overcome some of the shenanigans from
big tech
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you